12 الف دولار امريكي قيمه اغلى هديه
تلقاها الرئيس جو بايدن عام 2021 ضمن
تقليدا يتبع في الاعراف الدبلوماسيه
والدوليه لتبادل الهدايا بين الرؤساء
والمسؤولين الرقم ليس مفاجئا نظرا لمكانه
الرئيس جو بايدن كرئيسا لاقوى دوله في
العالم ولكن المفاجاه تبقى في صاحب الهديه
هل انتم مستعدون انه الرئيس الروسي
فلاديمير بوتين ولا احد غيره
[موسيقى]
لم تمنع التوترات بين بيض وبوتين من تبادل
الهدايا في جناب عام 2021 فاهدى بايدن
زوجا من نظراته الشمسيه افييتر للرئيس
بوتين الذي رد عبر منح مجموعه مكتبا من
المنممات المطليه على اليد التي تمثل اقدم
الفنون الروسيه الاثريه وتبلغ قيمتها 12
الف دولار لكن السعر في هذه الحاله لن
يكون له علاقه بقوه علاقتهما الفعليه فبعد
ثمانيه اشهر بدات الحرب في اوكرانيا وتحول
الرجلان لغريمين في السياسه
[موسيقى]
هديه بوتين لم تكن الوحيده التي تلقاها
بعيدا عام 2021 فبحسب التقرير السنوي
لوزاره الخارجيه الامريكيه تلقى بايدن
هدايا من الملكه البريطانيه الراحله
اليزابيث عباره عن صوره لها في اطار فضي
تبلغ قيمتها الفين دولار
[موسيقى]
كما اعطى رئيس الوزراء البريطاني انذاك
زوجا من اطباق للكلاب وفي صيفي 2021 اهدى
اشرف غني رئيس افغانستاني انذاك بايدن
سجاده حريريه بقيمه تسعه الاف دولار بينما
اهدى زوجته
سجاده حريريه اخرى بقيمه
19,200 دولار في بطون اسابيع كان غني يفر
من البلاد بعد ان استولى الطالبا على
كابول بعد انسحاب القوات الامريكيه من
افغانستان
الهدايا ترمز للتعاون الدولي والصداقه بين
دول وقاده غالبا ما تفصل بينهم محيطات
وايديولوجيات مع العلم ان معظم هذه
الهدايا تسلم للارشيف الوطني ما لم يدفع
قيمتها الرئيس ومع ذلك لا تزال بعض
الهدايا مفقوده خاصه تلك التي قدمت للرئيس
السابق دونالد ترامب ريتا سليمان لصباح
العربيه واشنطن